Catholic.
>> I'm a born again.
>> So you believe
>> my family My family has been um
Christians basically all our
generations.
>> But obviously
>> where you from if you don't mind asking
you.
>> I'm from Jamaica, bro.
>> No, not all generations. Christianity
was brought to you in Jamaica, brother.
How you say all generations?
>> Say again.
>> Christianity was brought to you by the
white men.
>> You know Christianity was the first ever
religion. Why do you think the Bible was
written first? Can you show me the word
Christianity in the Old Testament? Go
ahead.
>> I What should I show you? What the Okay,
let me quickly get my um app ready.
>> Yeah, gave me the Jesus never called
himself Christian. So, the Old Testament
the Christianity never existed until
Paul. The first person to use the word
Christians is Paul.
>> Okay, but make this make sense. If you
Okay, hold on. If you make Let's make
this make sense quickly. Yeah, because
>> we have to be very specific in what we
say because the truth will set everyone
free. Nothing but the truth.
>> That's right.
>> Jesus is the only way we can get an
encounter with God.
>> So you ask me this question, I should
get stuff from the I I should get the
meaning of Christianity into
>> No, no, the meaning don't bring me
explanation.
>> There's so many versions.
>> Show me the word Christian. No, brother.
No, brother. Show me the word Christian
or Christianity in the Old Testament.
Don't bring me something and listen.
>> This is what I'm saying. This is pure
delusion. Show me the word Christianity,
brother. You have to be more specific.
>> So the Christianity, you have to be
follow of Christ. Correct.
>> Of course.
>> Show me what Abraham said. I'm the
follower of the Christ. Go ahead.
>> I could show you in Genesis.
>> God told him to give up his son. What
did he do? He actually did. What did he
do next? God sent down angel to tell him
because what you have done your nation
will be blessed. So brother like
>> so so so there's no so there's no
passage in the Bible where
>> there's so many passages in the Bible I
don't know where to start to have good
conversation so in the Old Testament
Abraham never said I'm a follower of
Christ whereas in the Bible that Abraham
when God told to his son Abraham
submitted to God's commandments however
God replaced him with another with with
a sheep okay so there is no passive in
the Bible Yes. With the sheep.
Abraham.
The lamb was a sacrifice. The lamb.
Yeah. The lamb. Yeah.
>> Yeah. The lamb was a sacrifice.
>> So anyway, so there's no clear passage.
So So now let us go back. Let's go back
to Jamaica.
>> Can I wait? Can I ask you a question?
>> Jamaicans never heard about the word
Christianity. Jamaicans were not
Christians. Okay. Jamaicans, Native
Americans.
>> What was we, brother?
>> Native native Jamaicans. They were not
Christians. Christianity was brought to
you by the white man and force it onto
the to the to the people of uh Jamaica,
Brazil, people of America. All right,
Bubba. So, you are just making no sense,
bro. I have respect. You're making no
sense,
>> bro. Bro, the Christianity was brought
through Jesus Christ. He God used God.
Why do you think And this is the
question I want to answer for you all
you Muslims that think that okay, why do
we pray to Jesus? Wait, wait, bro. Bro,
bro, please.
>> Wait, wait, one second. So, Christianity
was brought to us through Jesus,
correct?
>> Yeah. No, no, not through Jesus, but
through the prophets.
>> Which prophets?
>> But mainly, that's why God sent his only
begotten son to come down because Wait,
bro. Bro, bro, bro,
which prophet came with Christianity?
Which prophet?
>> There's so many prophets is in the
Bible.
can show us where you know brother the
word Judaism which is ordinary
Christianity is not in the old testament
there's no word there's no Judaism in
the old testament let alone Christianity
there's nowhere in the bible or the old
testament where any prophet said I'm
coming with a Christianity or coming to
the Christ okay according to your belief
you believe Jesus was a god and a man at
the same time correct
>> no no okay thank god you brought this up
cuz I'm about to cook your ass up okay
>> let's say that we
Oh, cool. My bad, brother. All right, go
ahead.
>> Imagine, okay, let's put let's put in
this context. Yeah, God is a spirit.
Yeah, it's a supernatural spirit.
Imagine God coming down to people
proclaiming the word of the Lord. The
message would not get sent. The the the
the agenda of the message wouldn't be
portrayed in the right manner because
people would be scared. Why do you think
God had to send down Jesus? Because if
he came down in spirit form, everyone
would be scared. The message wouldn't
make sense. So he see
>> that was my question. My question, you
believe Jesus was God and a man same
time? That's my question.
>> No, that's bro. That's
>> So Jesus was on the earth. You believe
he was just 100% man. He was not God at
all.
>> No, he was he was God. He was sent. He
was a representation of God in human
form.
>> Was he God or representation of God?
>> Representation of God. Why do you think
God prayed? I mean, why do you think
Jesus prayed for God days and 40 nights?
>> By the way, believe you are you not
you're not you you are.
>> This is what I'm saying. You do this.
It's delusion, bro. I'm just teaching
you about your religion. Do you know
what is nas
believe that you believe go Jesus was
goat and a man at the same time?
>> No. This is this is where we get
confused. This is where you are a
heretic. According to Nian's belief, you
are a heretic.
Bro, this is where you guys get so
confused. And it's even in the Quran.
You guys claim you guys call him Isa,
right?
>> Okay, brother. To show you that I don't
Okay, let me show you.
>> You guys call him Isa, right?
>> Before I tell you what I call him, let
me show you what I have to understand
that I know your better than you. Okay.
>> Oh my god.
>> What book is this?
>> That's not even the real Bible, bro.
>> There's no Bible. Just read. Read
>> dead the Dead Sea Scrolls Bible.
>> Read. Carry on.
The oldest known Bible translated for
the first time into English.
>> By who? He's not Muslim.
>> By Martin Abeg
Jr. Peter Flynn and
>> Okay.
>> You don't even know who are they.
Anyway, but anyway, this is the the I
have your the oldest here. So, what they
did, they translated the oldest one.
Yeah. The first ever
written was the Old Testament. This is
this is what I'm saying.
That was written by that was probably
written by Muslim men and he changed his
name.
>> They're Christian scholars. Where you
on,
>> bro?
>> Oh, brother. You You need to wake up,
bro. You need to to wake up.
>> You guys need to have no clue what you
talking about. They are
>> brother. What are you talking about? You
brother, go check them. Go check. Oh my
god.
>> Anyway. Anyway, let's go back to the
point. The point here is that we
Muslims, Islam, when we talk about
Islam,
>> but Jesus was never, he never said he
was God, though. This is where you guys
are getting it confused. He Why do you
think he prayed to God? Why do you think
he prayed to God for 40 days and 40
nights? But I'm saying
>> if he was God, we wouldn't be praying.
>> Listen to me. You are a heretic
according to Nian's belief. Na, do you
know what Na's belief?
>> No, you tell me. Educate me.
>> The council of Na.
>> Educate me.
We don't know bro are you serious? The
counc of na took place when all the
Christian scholars and and church
fathers came all together to discuss the
nature of Jesus
and all they came to conclusion that the
nature Jesus had two nature God and a
man same time and anyone that believe
believe otherwise they called him a
heretic. Okay. So if you are born again
Christian this what they believe
>> bro we only believe in the Bible. This
is all all the other
>> No, you have your own belief. Anyway, I
don't mind. Okay. The Bible. Let me ask
you something. Can you trust the Bible?
>> Of course you can trust the Bible.
>> What are the Bible? The manuscript.
Listen carefully to my question. Yeah.
Listen carefully.
>> Can you tell me what is the earliest
manuscript for the New Testament?
>> Say it again.
>> You know, you know the the Bible that
you follow. Is it King James?
>> Yeah. King James. Yeah.
>> Okay. King James was not written by John
himself or Luke or Matthew or Mark. King
James is based upon a manuscript was
discovered
long time ago. Okay, that manuscript
came way after John and Paul and Mark
and Matthew literally hundreds of years
after was written by scribes. So the the
manuscripts of King James that King
James is based upon was written by
scribes who never met Paul, Mark, Luke,
Matthew, John. Do you know them?
>> Listen, the Bible was written through
revelations.
>> Do you know Do you know Do you know who
>> Bro, you can't say no. This is pure
facts, bro. You can't you can't do that,
bro.
>> Bro, what facts? What are you talking
about, D?
>> It's facts, bro. Bro, come on, bro. So,
okay. Same way if prophet Muhammad
was an illiterate he couldn't read or
write or write. Right. So where how did
this Quran get written?
>> One second. One second for you to
understand.
>> No prophet could not read or write. So
how how did the how how how did the
Quran ever come about?
>> Before we talked about the Quran I want
to understand a point. So this is the
Bible King James. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> This King James. Okay. Now I'm going to
show you another Bible which is ESV.
Okay. ESV. All right. So, for you to
understand what I'm talking about step
by step. All right. Okay. One second.
All right. So, uh this is uh ESV. All
right. Uh
one second. Cuz you know this very old.
So ESV is it is it uh look the Old
Testament. All right.
>> So ESV I have ESV here and I have King
James. So both of them is from God.
Correct.
>> Yep.
>> All right. So now you please help me. If
you have do you have ESV at home?
>> No. No. I only have the Bible, brother.
>> Yeah brother. I have that this called
Bible. ESV Bible.
>> Yeah. I've I mean I've already got the
King James version. Sorry.
>> ESV. If you have ESV, you go to Matthew
17:21. If I go to Matthew 17:21, it's
not here. It's not there. There's
nothing. It's gap. It goes from 20 to
22. Do you know why?
>> Yeah. God.
>> You know why? Do you know why?
>> God.
>> Okay. I'll tell you why. Because
>> Can I ask you a question? Can I ask you
a question, brother? Please. before
before ESV is based upon a manuscript
that came earlier than the manuscript of
the new of the the King James. So what
they did the Christian scholars and
researchers they discovered manuscripts
back dates came before the manuscript
that King James utilized to translate
the uh the the the New Testament or the
Bible. So, and now you have to
understand here they tell you if you go
back to the early manuscript which came
before
King James 1, Matthew 17:21 does not
exist. I'll show you where.
>> Okay. What does this ESV start with
Genesis?
>> Yeah, it starts with everything. It's
just another Bible. Look, look, I'll
show you. Look this Old Testament. All
right. Here, Genesis.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. But there are some passages
it's it's not here but it's here is in
is in King James. Okay. You know King
James never met Jesus. King James was a
king of England.
>> Listen.
>> So what I'm saying to you brother how
can you trust scribes those who wrote
the manuscript of the New Testament that
came 100 years after
John and Mark and Luke and Matthew. You
don't even know them. How can you trust
them?
Bro, because you guys are going off the
wrong. The first ever book was not the
ESV. It's only stated that way. No, bro.
I'm I'm not going to lie to you, bro,
because there's a lot of revelations
that wasn't revealed through the ASV.
But if you look at the other,
do you understand my point?
>> Of course, I understand what you're
saying to me.
>> What is my point? Please break it down
for me. What is my point? You're
basically saying that
how can we as Christians believe a book
that was apparently never ever written
by Paul or do you know what I mean?
That's what you're basically trying to
say.
>> No, what I'm saying for the sake of
argument except
>> the Bible was written through
revelations through Jesus. Bro,
>> uh listen carefully. You have to
differentiate between
>> the question is how did the Quran
>> before before the Quran
>> the actual look look you have to
differentiate between the actual writers
and the manuscript for example now
there's a books that was written by
Aristotal but we don't have the original
writing of Aristot where we have a copy
of a copy likewise the new testament we
do not have the original writing of the
new Testament. Well, we do have a copy
of a copy of a copy of a copy of a copy
of the original writing. So, the
original writing, we don't have it
anymore.
>> You're saying a very key word, original.
>> Yeah, we don't have original anymore.
>> Original. And guess what? It goes to
show that Christianity is the only
original religion. How can you guys
claim to be
>> Okay, bro. It all Yeah, bro. It all
correlates. The book religion, it all
correlates to my brother. What I'm
saying the original writing like for
example the original book that was
written by Matthew or or Luke or Mark or
John or Paul we don't have their own
writing what we have manuscripts which
was written by scribes is a copy of a
copy of a copy of a copy because it was
a long time we don't have the original
books that was written by the original
authors like Mark Matthew Luke John so
the scholars Like I give you example.
Dead scroll. You know death is scroll.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. Dead scroll. What does it have? It
has the Old Testament. Correct.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay. The Old Testament within it. What
is it? Torah. The five books. Genesis.
>> The Torah was given to whom?
>> The Torah was given what? Wait. Say that
again. The Torah.
>> Torah was given to whom? To Moses.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. The the dead scroll. the gap
between the dead the dead screw and
Moses 1,000 years. So someone came
nearly 10,000 years and he wrote the
manuscript which we call dead scroll
which we discover in a Cameron cave and
that manuscript was written by someone
came 1,000 years. How can you trust
someone wrote that scroll who never met
Moses who came 1,000 years after Moses?
How can you trust him?
Because you know you know why I I trust
him.
>> Yeah. Go on. Do you know him by the way?
>> Who?
>> The one who that's his clue.
>> I know of him but I don't know him
personally.
>> If you don't know him, how can you trust
him?
>> Same way I could say with the Quran.
We'll all go around in circles.
>> No, we're not going in circle. If you
I'm sure if you don't know, you don't
know me. If I ask you for your pin
number, for your credit card, for your
bank card, you will never give it to me.
So your belief is more important than
the bank card that you have. So why are
you going to trust the dead scroll
scribe? We don't know. And you have no
clue who it was. And you're making no
sense, Bedrin.
>> Bro, I am making sense, bro.
>> I am making sense, but you guys have a
way of flipping. This is what you guys
do. You take little things and you run
with it. You take I'm not I'm not
>> but you don't want to answer my
questions. You just want to talk about a
a a mish hidden passage that was written
thousands of years ago and you guys
don't want the truth.
>> D I'm I'm just I'm just utilizing the
intellect in the Bible. What does he
say? Let's let's reason. Hh let's
reason. Let's utilize our reasoning.
What I'm saying to you simply you have a
dirty scroll which King James is based
upon. Now,
>> okay, please tell me. Okay, bro, please
tell me. Yeah, if Jesus isn't real and
all of this, why do so many Muslims
Yeah. Why do so many Muslims believe in
Jesus? You guys call him Isa, right?
>> Firstly, I I never claimed that Jesus is
not real. I don't I didn't say that. So,
I believe in Jesus. I I'm saying to you,
>> so if you believe in Jesus, if you
believe in Jesus, where is this
conversation going, bro? You just said
>> the conversation is going to that you as
a Christian you have no criteria or you
believe I do have criteria blind follow
>> I'm not a blind following brok
I'm asking you a question about the
Quran as well you don't you don't want
to ask
>> so so when it comes to Quran Quran we do
not rely on the manuscripts the Quran
like I give you example
>> you had the hadith you have the hadith
and you have the Quran right
>> yes the Quran we have manuscripts also
we have Quran memor memorizes to to give
a to give you a clear example. Now if
tomorrow everyone wakes up in the
morning and we cannot find no Quran in a
physical form likewise the Bible the
only people that will be able to have
the Quran with them or the scripture is
with them is the Muslims because our
scriptures in our hearts that's why
there's a millions of Muslims the Quran
word for word letter for letter if we
don't have no
>> likewise likewise people in the Bible
they
>> no no no brother there's No one memorize
the Bible. No one.
>> Bro, how can you say there's no one that
ask?
>> Let me ask you. Tell me. What does it
say? Isaiah 42.
>> Bro, I don't know. Bro, I'm saying, bro,
this is what I'm saying. You can't say I
didn't say, bro, you now you're twisting
it cuz I did not I did not say that I
know the Bible in and out. I know. I
know a lot of scriptures.
>> I know a lot of scriptures.
>> Okay. What does it say in Isaiah 42?
shall I tell you Isaiah 42 he says about
the servant who's who's coming to
glorify the Lord
speak about a servant who was coming to
glorify the Lord and he said I will put
my spirit upon him and he will bring
justice for the Gentiles and then he
says in 11 he says let the witness and
it cities lift up their voice the
village that ka inhabitant let the
inhabitant of silah sing so this speak
of the prophet Muhammad by the way but
we move we go to it after but anyway if
I so me we Muslims we have memorized a
lot of passages in the Bible but you
have not memorized the Bible there's no
one memorized the Bible the pope doesn't
know the Bible have not memorized the
Bible you see so we Muslims we have the
Quran has been passed down to us
generation by generations you know
>> the Quran was written basically on the
Bible's revelation why do you think you
have angel Gabriel in there why do you
think you have Jesus in there. Why do
you think you have so many of our people
in there, bro?
>> Why are you talking at your people? It's
like they're from Jamaica. Your people.
What are you talking about?
>> They're not from,
>> bro. Let's not do the thing, bro.
>> Let's not do the country. I'm not being
racist or nothing like I'm joking with
you.
>> No, no, I hear you, bro. I hear you,
bro.
>> But anyway, listen. What I'm saying to
you that yes, there's something we do
agree with the Christians like Gabri,
the prophet, the angel Gabriel. But if
you go back to the Quran like you there,
>> what angel? What angel
came down to Mary? What angel came on to
Mary to announce the arrival of Jesus?
>> We believe the angel Gabriel.
>> Thank you. So this is what I'm saying.
You're using all of
>> you know you know sorry D you know you
know the story about Mary in the Quran
is more logical than the story of Mary
in your book.
>> I've never heard it. So bro it down.
I've never heard
>> a good question. So let us break it
down. So let me ask you this question
first de imagine
>> you know the Quran did Allah say he was
a deceiver right?
>> We're gonna come to it. We're gonna come
to it.
>> Okay no problem.
>> Uh so you want to deal with this uh God
saying he's a deceiver? Okay I'll show
you where the Quran says that. Let me
show you the the passage.
>> I think that's wild to me. You know like
a god to say he's a deceiver.
>> Not only that what he done to Aisha. Not
only that he can't read or write. It's
just a lot of things ain't added up. No,
let me show you where God says it is.
>> And you guys talk about Rebecca being 3
years old. In the Bible, it says she was
a young child. Listen, you mentioned too
many points. You mentioned too many
points. Let us just uh uh what do you
call it? Uh point by point, okay? To to
deal with it. All right.
>> So,
>> uh Okay. Uh okay. This is the
I want to show you something. One
second. The uh Okay.
Okay. Can you read this please for me?
>> Yeah, I would. Yep. I don't think I
could see it, bro. I'm not going to lie
to you, brother.
>> Okay. This is This is here. It says in
number seven. It says,
>> "Oh Lord, you have deceived me and I was
deceived." That is in the Quran, by the
way.
>> Uhhuh.
>> That's not the Quran, by the way. This
is Jeremiah. I'm reading from your
Bible.
>> Okay. So, he said that he was deceived.
So,
>> in Jeremiah, God Jeremiah said to God,
"You deceived me.
Bro,
>> what happened? Where'd you go?
>> Okay, now I'm just going to show you
where God himself said, "I the Lord
deceive from your own book." Watch this.
Okay. Now,
so now you have to be consistent. Uh uh
Okay. Here in uh in uh Ezekiel. All
right. 14:9. And if the prophet is
deceived and speaks words, I the Lord
have deceived that prophet. Here.
>> Yeah. Say that again. Just no. Repeat
that.
>> I repeat again. Okay. Repeat.
>> Ezekiel. Ezekiel.
>> So God says, "And if the prophet is
deceived and speaks a word, I the Lord
have deceived that prophet."
>> So you go,
>> he's talking about false prophets.
That's what he means by that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. But so you go deceive. You
go deceive.
>> Yeah. That's what I'm saying. But he
meant what God meant by that is false
prophets.
>> Okay. So in the Quran, Allah deceived
the ones like false prophets.
>> Okay. So if
>> you have go deceiving now. Yeah.
>> No, bro. Cuz you It's not making sense,
bro. God is
>> shown you that God never said God never
said.
>> Is Jeremiah a false prophet? Sorry.
Jeremiah saying he's talking about false
prophets.
>> Okay. Is Jeremiah false prophet?
>> Jeremiah was never a false prophet. So
Jam said, "Oh God, you have deceived
me."
>> "Oh God, you have deceived me." But
break, let me break it down.
>> Yeah. Here. 27. Okay.
>> Read the whole context. Read, not just
that one. You guys like reading one
line. Read the whole thing.
>> No. No. You get You get your Bible. I
read the whole context. Read the whole
Bible. I don't mind.
>> Bro, you've got the Bible there.
>> Okay. Let me read cuz bring it close to
me cuz um Okay, let me read this for
you. So here he says he says where is
Jeremiah persecuted by pashure. Okay he
said oh lord you have deceived me and I
was deceived you are stronger than I and
you have prevailed. I have become a
laughingtock all the day everyone mocks
me for whenever I speak I cry out I
shout violence and destruction. So what
you mean to do through whole life?
Clearly J Daniel Jeremiah is saying to
God, you have deceived me because you're
stronger than me. And you told me only
God only deceive a false prophet. And
you just said Jeremiah is a true
prophet. So now you God deceive true
prophet. So what are you going to say
about that?
>> What Jeremiah said? Let me let me break
it down to you because bro,
>> you don't even know how you going to
break it down,
>> bro. Wait. Bro, let me break it down,
man.
Let let me let me break it down.
>> You don't even know how we going to
break it down. You know Christian they
make up anything. He's going to make
he's going to become now watch.
>> Anyway, look they become Muslim. Leave
Christianity and now so now you're
talking about you're talking about what
do you call it? God deceiving. It's your
own book. You didn't expect that did you
>> bro? No. No. But be honest about false
prophets bro.
That's that's the whole monologue. False
prophets.
>> Did you bro you can't use that against
you when God was specifically talking
about false prophets.
>> But Jeremiah said God deceived me.
>> He didn't. Look, you have to break cuz
for me to break it down, it's going to
take a long time, bro. You know what I
mean?
>> Take longer than the the Darwin
evolution. Cuz even if you break, even
if you go on Google and other Christian
websites, the whole definition,
>> what do you think about God saying to
someone,
>> you know, you know, did you know Isaiah?
>> Yeah, Isaiah. Yeah.
>> What was the miracle of Isaiah? Sign of
Isaiah.
>> What? The sign of Isaiah?
>> Yeah. As God gave Isaiah a sign or one
of the signs. Do you know what was it?
I think it was No, wait. Let me recall.
I think it was
a a moon.
>> Okay, let let me tell you. Okay,
brother, I'm not sure how old you are.
Imagine, brother, are you from London?
>> Yeah, bro.
>> Imagine you're walking in central London
and you see old man walking naked in the
street. What do you think about him?
I think he's mad.
>> He's mad. Imagine if he tells you, "God
told me to do it." Would you believe
him?
>> No. That's insanity. I would never
believe him.
>> Insanity. Okay. Let us read what Isaiah
says. Okay. If you go to Isaiah 22.
Okay.
So, here 22.
uh
>> what mind you when God so at that time
the Lord spoke by Isaiah the son of Amos
saying go and loose the
suckle from your waist and take off your
sandals from your feet and he did so
walking naked and bare feet. So God said
to Isaiah, "Take off his sandal and take
off his clothes." And he was walking
naked
>> because Okay, let me give you a good
definition.
>> What are you smoking by the way? What
are you smoking?
>> Vape. Vape.
>> Are you sure?
>> I used I used to smoke. No, I used to
smoke weed. I'm not going to lie, but I
don't do that no more, bro.
>> I think you should go back to it. I'm
joking.
>> No, no, no.
>> I'm joking. It's haram. But anyway,
>> so what do you think about God telling
someone big man to walk naked?
>> You wouldn't, you know, I wouldn't be
surprised because when God was getting
crucified, the same thing happened.
>> Who?
>> God, when when Jesus, sorry, was getting
crucified,
>> he was naked.
>> B, he wasn't naked, but he was
basically, bro, if you looked at the the
the bro, if you look at the if you read
the passage and if you read if you look
at the the message and the film and
whatever, you can see that God basically
>> forget about the film, brother. We don't
watch films about Jesus. We don't we
respect Jesus. But anyway, so here
there's more, you know, there's more.
One second. And the Lord said, "As my
servant Isaiah has walked naked and
barefoot for three years."
So imagine
God told Isaiah to walk naked for three
years. And of course for three years
walking naked, there were children out
there.
He was not walking in by himself in the
earth. There was children, woman. Is
that a good thing for a man to walk
naked in front of his front of children?
>> I think, bro, that that was a metaphor,
bro. You know why? I didn't break it
down.
>> It's not a metaphor. No, no, no, no, no,
no. Don't lie.
>> He meant his spirit. His spirit was
>> No, it doesn't say metaphor. Just made
it up. Doesn't say.
>> No, it's not. It's not me. It's the bro
he was referring to.
>> Literally, it literally says here, look,
literally the Lord said, "As my servant
Isaiah has walked naked and bear fruit
for three years as a sign and protest
against Egypt." So that was a sign for a
man to walk naked was protesting against
Egypt.
>> Yes. Basic he was.
>> So that's why I say D. He wasn't.
>> You people have not no leg to stand on
to criticize Islam or what
you probably wouldn't even
>> so I advise you literally look you seem
a nice guy respectful guy would become
respectful bro I don't come here to be
>> yeah what I would say to you your voice
is gone your voice is gone.
>> Yeah bro my voice is still here bro.
>> Yeah I okay the mic I think the mic you
cover the mic maybe. Yeah. Yeah. Can you
hear me now, bro?
>> Yeah. Now, can you What I say to you,
look, seriously,
let me go back to the story of Mary.
Yeah. Before to show you what Islam is
more logical, why did you know that
churches in Britain are turning into
swimming pools?
>> There's a lot of false prophets out
here. I understand. I agree with you on
that one.
>> You know, Christianity, imagine the
Western world who forced Christianity
upon us. French occupied Algeria for 132
years and they they forced us and they
killed us just for the sake of becoming
a Christians. But look to France now
France, Britain, uh Holland, Germany,
Belgium these countries went to Africa,
to Asia, to Caribbean to to South
America to force Christianity upon us.
The same people have left it completely.
Uh we have we have bought two churches
and we turned it into mosques. One in
East London and one in Birmingham.
Okay.
>> Alhamdulillah. You become Muslim. We we
we took churches and we send it to
mosques. So now let me tell you the
story of Mary in the Quran. You know to
show you Prophet Muhammad is a true
prophet. There's no chapter in the Quran
is been named after the mother of
prophet Muhammad. But what we do find
there is a chapter is been named after
mother of Jesus. If he was a false
prophet, he would have named a chapter
after his own mother. Why is going to
name it after someone else mother?
>> One thing. The other point Satum
lineage David the tribe of Judah.
>> Same lineage, bro. So you can't we can't
say we can't say that.
Oh, because one scripture wasn't named
after Mary. That that was false. That
was just it doesn't if you do your
research, bro.
>> What was the say it again?
>> I said, bro, you we can't go off of one
like you can't say. Oh, because Mary
wasn't named in the Bible. But if you
look at the lineage of Mary, David comes
from that. They all come from Judah,
right?
[Music]
>> Judah. You know Judah, bro?
>> Go ahead. Yeah. Yeah, I'm listening.
>> Yes. So bro, they all come from the same
lineage, bro. So this all goes to show,
bro.
>> But you see my point, my point is that
why a man lived in the middle of
nowhere, when he lived, there was many
rather when he was in Medina, there were
many Israelites who were saying that
Jesus was a bastard when he had was a
false prophet. So a false prophet was
someone who claimed to be
>> because Mary wasn't, you know, Mary
didn't sleep with no one.
>> No, I'm I'm coming to that. Yeah, listen
my point. My point is
>> listen carefully. If Prophet Muhammad
was a false prophet, he would have
agreed with the Israelites in Medina to
gain more followers. But what he did, he
he he defended the honor of Mary that
she was a pure woman. She was not
fornicator. And he defended the honor of
Jesus.
>> Mary was a virgin, brother.
>> Huh?
>> Mary was a virgin.
>> No, she was tumobile. Of course, I don't
choose a virgin brother. I'm not that. I
know. Okay. I know. But you miss the
point. The point here is it's not mobile
or virgin brother. It's about that she
prophet Muhammad in Medina.
He was defending the the honor of Mary
the mother of Jesus defending the owner
of Jesus against the Israelites. If he
was a false pro prophet, he would have
agreed with them. Now let us go back to
the story of Mary in the Quran and the
Bible. In the Bible that God sent
Gabriel and she got pregnant. However,
because according to the Old Testament,
if a woman get pregnant and she has no
uh what they call it uh partner,
husband, then they will stone her to
death. Are you aware of that?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, and now she's pregnant.
>> Why did you think they didn't do that to
Mary?
>> Wait, we're coming to it. I'm coming to
it. Wait.
>> Okay.
>> So, and now she got pregnant. Now she
has to defend herself otherwise the
rabbis they will stone her to death. So
Gabriel came
>> she didn't defend herself. God defended.
>> Wait wait wait. We're going to see that
story. So as Gabriel came to Joseph
Carpenter and told him to marry her. All
right.
>> Yeah.
>> For for the people to not accuse her.
But everyone knows Joseph Carpenter
who's not is not the father of Jesus.
She's had no father. So the story
doesn't make any sense.
>> Imagine
>> that's how you know it makes sense
because the whole theory of what you
guys believe in. You guys think that we
worship two gods which is completely
false.
>> I'm not talking about woriing two gods.
I'm talking about something else now.
>> Bro, no. No, bro. This is what I'm
trying to say to you, bro.
>> Listen, listen, listen. Let me finish
then you can jump in. what I'm going to
say. So, uh uh
the imagine you have a daughter and she
comes to you and she says to you, "I'm
pregnant."
Obviously, you're going to ask her, "Are
you married?" She said, "No." "Do you
have a partner?" "No." She will say to
you, "I'm pregnant. God me pregnant. Is
a miracle." Are you going to believe
her?
>> Of course. Of course.
>> You're going to believe her? How?
Because God is a supernatural God. He He
can make the impossible.
>> How can she prove that to you? She's
maybe she's not lying to you,
>> bro. We can't use ordinary people to
compare like God like bro that error was
a very
look I know you deep down you're not
going to believe her. You're going to
say what? But imagine that's when the
story of the Quran comes in.
>> She mentioned God. Why wouldn't I have
believe her? She if she just said it was
like random. If you didn't mention God,
I wouldn't I wouldn't.
>> If anyone mentioned God, to you, believe
him then.
>> If there if there, bro, not any god. If
you're talking about my God, 100% I'm
going to believe them, bro.
>> Okay. Bush. Bush. He said God of the
Christian told him to invade Iraq. Would
you believe him?
>> Say it again.
>> Bush. You know Bush. George Bush. He
said God told him, the God of the
Christians, he's a Christian. God told
him to invade Iraq. Would you believe
him? I wouldn't believe him cuz that's a
that's a work of the devil.
>> But the same God though you told me my
god is your god told him. No more bro
that's you making no sense baba you keep
making I believe anyway but if she comes
to you and she said you know you have to
show that my God has power for that to
happen that should be an eye opener
>> listen if she comes to you now she says
I prove to you that God got me pregnant
with a miracle because my child who was
in the cradle will speak to you now
you're going to say wow that is a
miracle
how a child in the cradle is speaking.
That's the story of the Quran.
>> We're talking about a God that rose
Jesus up after 3 days after he got
crucified. We're talking about a God
that healed the sick. We're talking
about a God that rose the dead, made the
blind see. So if that can happen, what
makes that happen?
>> I did I did take care of yourself. Have
a good day.
But like
>> bro, like exactly. You don't want to
talk the sense, bro. Like
>> brother, you're not talking no sense,
brother. I'm talking about sense.
>> I am talking sense, bro. It's in the
Bible. This is my body.
>> I'm saying this is what I'm saying. What
I'm saying to you, I'm saying to you
that Mr. L. What I'm saying to you, I'm
saying that if my daughter comes to me
or to you, you will not believe that
believer until she brings a miracle or a
clearcut proof. So the Quranic story
Allah made Jesus in the cradle when he
was few months old to speak to defend
and protect the owner of his mother.
That's why the rabbis could not
stone her to death cuz they knew yes
she's speaking the truth because there's
no child can speak in the cradle.
So the Quranic story is more logical
rational. The Bible story doesn't make
any sense, bro.
>> Because the reason why it don't make any
sense, bro. Yeah. Is because
>> it doesn't make sense then.
>> No. Wait. No. To you. The reason why it
doesn't make any sense to you.
>> No, it's changing day.
>> No, bro. No. Look, bro. Like, take care
of yourself, man. I have to go,
>> bro. Come on,
>> man. Next time. Next time. Take care of
yourself. Have a good night. Have a good
night. All right. Have a good night day.
It was nice speaking to you, but you
need to become Muslim, bro. you know to
become Muslim you're just joking around
and you know I showed you many things
you didn't expect you tried to talk
about prophet Muhammad about is bro you
have your Bible you have Isaiah was
walking three years naked showing his
private part to kids everyone street and
you want to talk about my prophet come
on man anyway stop inshallah cuz I have
to go a day by the way we'll be doing
dawa table tomorrow you're more than
welcome to come visit us in shebat bush
outside central line station will be
giving dawahham
sleep.